hello my name is noah yi and i live at
the vulcan in east oakland california
and for my ija 2012 video competition i
will be doing a reverse boy fishtail it
looks a little bit like this
a fishtail is a trick that can be
transferred between a wide variety of
props
it can be incorporated into your club
swinging
your
contact staff or staff spinning
or even random objects in case you want
to do it for a renegade show
the fishtail has a learning curve very
similar to traditional juggling props it
takes dedication time and a little
practice to get salt
the traditional fish tail with the rigid
crop like a staff or club
one end of the staff does not leave the
one side of the body
the poi fish tail is a little bit
different
the handle of the poi switches from
parallel planes each side this is the
difference that makes the poi fishtail
different from the normal ridgid
professional and so interesting and fun
it is best to practice poi fishtails
with the type of poi called a contact
poi the poi head is a ball and the
handle is weighted to provide
counterweight for your fishtail
you can begin with any port but i
suggest the contact poi as the illusion
of the fishtail is maintained
here i'm using an 80 millimeter stage
ball and a set of flow cord from flow
toys
the next most important thing you want
to practice is to think about which
cradle you'd like to learn for your
contact toy fishtail so
here we go
i like the three finger cradle here
because it's prettier than the four
finger cradle and it's not as hard as a
two finger cradle but any one you choose
will work
in the first of our four drills you will
not be using any poi at all
taking a stage ball and putting it into
your favorite cradle
move the ball around from side to side
changing between parallel planes
after you're comfortable give it a
little hop
the hop should happen at the very center
line of your body
this will get you used to the string and
handle switching from side to side
another drill teaches us how to move
from a hold into a balance
to begin grab the head of the poi
and swing in reverse on one side of your
body give the poi a little toss and
balance it on the back of your hand
absorbing the impact toss it back up and
catch it in the hand again
when you're comfortable with this catch
go ahead and try balancing your hand and
swinging the handle to the other side of
your body
try to make sure that you're giving it a
little bit of a pop as you move it to
the other side to get that handle over
one beat to the wayside and then back
home and stop don't try to keep going
quite yet just try to get started with
two beats and eventually you move up to
more and more
in the third drill
you start by swinging your poi back and
forth on your side as the poi handles on
the way up swing the handle to the other
side and stop
and end in the swing i find this drill
focuses the attention on the swinging
aspect of the fishtail
if you find it difficult to stop on the
other side
go back and practice your basic balance
the fourth poi fishtail drill starts by
adding a softer swing to the technique
start by holding the handle in one hand
and the ball on the other and drop the
handle and try to get a few rotations
out of the poi and then re-catch in the
original position
once again build up with two beats then
gradually add more until it's comfy
practicing all four of these point
fishtail drills will improve your
fishtails drastically
some drills work for some people some
work for others so pick the ones you
like best and work on those or maybe
come up with your own
remember small steps try to get one bead
of the fishtail and then two and then
three and then build up build up
confidence while practicing
so
changed
cheers
oh
so
thanks for watching my iga tutorial
video on reverse poi fishtails
subscribe
become a member of the ija and see you
next time bye